it means a freedom
a lot of people that i know has fought
for this flag
when marine corps veteran richard
jenkins got a flag for father's day
the 77 year old had no idea the
controversy it would stir
as americans everybody should have a
right to put a flag in the ground
but the willow shade homeowners
association says jenkins did not get
proper approval for the 20-foot pole
which the culpepper hoa wants taken down
abc 7 called the hoa president but so
far we have not heard back
why move here if you can't follow the
hoa rules which say
you can't erect a structure without
getting approval first well tim let's
put it this way
there was no rules neighbor wally bunker
says the hoa does not have guidelines
for flags
i'll be honest with you tamara i was the
president of the hoa for eight years
and the flag issue never came up after
jenkins raised his flag in a flagpole
his neighbor across the street
raised his own flag in a flagpole then
another neighbor
and another neighbor tonight there's
going to be a total of eight
when he put up one i said hey come on
put up one tune what's the problem
it's too pretty take down everybody
likes looking at my flag
and none of the flagpole flying
neighbors have plans to take their flags
down
it means a lot to us our family enough
old glory
reporting from culpepper virginia tim
barber abc 7 news